foreign
foreign
true enough
on the area of the leopard a coalition I
think is they're calling themselves it
has been reported that obviously Poland
is very keen to donate some leopard as
is Finland who have expressed all of
this currently relies on the German
government's decisions not only whether
the Germans will supply their own
leopards but whether or not they'll give
permissions for others I would urge my
German colleagues to do that these tanks
are not offensive when they are used for
defensive methods you know there's a
debate in Germany at the moment about
whether a tank is an offensive weapon or
a defensive weapon well depends what
you're using it for if you're using it
to defend your country I would wager
that it is a defensive weapon system
secondly uh we are not on our own this
is a joint International Coalition and I
know there have been concerns in the
German political body that they don't
want to go alone while they're not alone
and I think the conference in Ramstein
will show that today I can announce the
most significant package of combat power
to date to accelerate Ukrainian success
this includes a squadron of Challenger 2
tanks with armored recovery and repair
vehicles
we will donate as90 guns to Ukraine this
compromises a batch comprises a battery
of eight guns at high Readiness and two
further batteries at varying states of
readiness
this donation will not impact our
existing as-90 commitment in Estonia
hundreds more armored and protected
Vehicles will also be sent including
bulldog
a maneuver support package including
Minefield breaching and bridging
capabilities worth 28 million pounds and
dozens more uncrewed aerial systems
worth 20 million to support Ukrainian
artillery
another 100 000 artillery Rand on top of
a hundred thousand rounds already
delivered
hundreds more sophisticated missiles
including gmrs Rockets star streak air
defense and medium range air defense
missiles
an equipment's a poor package of spares
to refurbish up to 100 Ukrainian tanks
and infantry fighting vehicles
ah
the bathroom